march madness is upon us duke head coach
mike szyszewski is set to retire as
perhaps the greatest college basketball
coach of all time and you must
acknowledge his greatness
the final home game with coach mike
shishevsky's duke coaching career this
was the entry for the man the myth the
legend 96 former players came to support
him jerry seinfeld and nba commissioner
adam silver were among those in the
building i don't even know what to say
it's like part of my basketball life is
disappearing thank you coach k and go
duke
please
you know you didn't see in that video
a lot of black people over 35.
we kind of hate that dude
we hate that he beat every team black
people loved
ten years ago if duke would have played
the klu klux klan we would have rooted
for a zero zero tie
however to much of the nation duke
basketball was like venture capital
speaking with a manager bringing your
dog to work
symbolic of white excellence
just like these excellent white duke
alums richard nixon richard spencer and
the man who wears his heart on his
hairline stephen miller
coach k brought those excellent vibes to
durham in 1980. just listen to how we
talked about their recruiting
what duke does it gives me it limits
some of my recruiting because not every
youngster can
get into duke and that doesn't mean that
kids who don't make it a duke are
worse or better it's just that schools
are for different kids
doesn't sound like he was recruiting the
kids from rosa parks high school
let me be clear coach k's legacy is
built on society's perception of
whiteness the idea that his players
overcame their physical deficiencies
that they were harder working smarter
not as athletic
being good made coach k a star being
better than us made him a legend
and that's not coach k being racist
but the rest of you
i don't know
so let me take it back to 1980. the
rising tide of blackness in college
basketball was a threat to the whole
game
that year the louisville cardinals won
their first championship
some people called them the black birds
yes
it only took a half black roster to get
a racist nickname back then
not quite the one drop rule but damn if
it don't feel the same
anyway soon after john thompson's
georgetown established itself as a power
black power
every single player on their 1984
championship team was black
if somebody would have called them the
black birds i would have understood
but in 1986 duke lost to louisville in
the national championship check out how
the chicago tribune felt about that
funk wins scholarship loses
so much for literacy drape all the
campus libraries in black
they really must have thought black
players could read if they printed that
[ __ ]
i mean it's not like white sports fans
had nothing to be proud of the best
player in the nba was larry bird
quarterbacks were still supposed to be
white and the heavyweight champions of
the world were these guys
but college basketball seemed on the
brink of eternal darkness
that's when coach k pulled up with the
caucasian avengers and their captain
america was this guy
now before you say anything we're not
erasing johnny dawkins grant hill and
other black devils but christian
leighton was so white he got caught
stepping on somebody and didn't even get
thrown out of the game
it was symbolic of why some people
didn't like christian you know in terms
of
him willing to cross the line and do
something a little bit arrogant it was
just a little love tap on his chest
[ __ ]
duke beat every team black folks loved
from 1986 to 92 georgetown arkansas unlv
and the one program that felt the most
like ours michigan's fab five
look at these cool [ __ ] black
socks long shorts pristine edge ups
well coach k and the supercuts all-stars
kick their fresh asses repeatedly
no wonder jaylen rose was salty about it
schools like duke didn't recruit players
like me i felt like they only recruited
black players that were uncle toms
too far jalen
but to be fair it seemed to me that the
press wasn't just rooting for duke they
were standing up for him along the way
i'm sure that the unlv players are
gaining some respect for the courage of
the duke players as well neither team
backing away
an important thing to consider when you
play georgetown they play you tough and
physical and the only way is to look
them straight in the eye and say we'll
play that way too i mean that's just
that's just the way it is athletically
and i don't think anybody should make
any
great big headline deal out the fab five
against america's finest coming up next
america's finest who are they the durham
pd
now remember at this point a lot of
folks love duke as much as they hated
hip-hop which was taking over everywhere
except college basketball
until now this was the closest rapid got
in the college ball
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but some of those iconic black teams
started bringing the culture right onto
the basketball court with them but not
duke coach k's kids didn't break it down
break beats or break dance you scratch a
record at danny fairy's house and you
owe him a new toto album
which is the closest africa got to duke
until luaua dang showed up
either way coach k was claiming all i do
is win way before a dj khaled
and yeah duke had a down year in 1995
but that got coach k to recruit outside
of his usual young republicans he
brought in some of the most talented
teams he ever had and they got really
good again
but then in 1999 for the first time ever
at duke
those guys left school early and took
all their swag with them to the nba
in 2006 coach k had figured out how to
go from steve urkel to stefan erkell
he became the coach of usa basketball
that got all the cool kids attention
you know i love coach kevin i love
playing for him i love talking to him on
off days and during practices and you
know uh you know i've been you know
blessed you know with me not having the
ability to go to college coming straight
out of high school to have a college
coach
lebron said he didn't have the ability
to go to college like he couldn't read
or something not because he was too
smart to pass up a 90 million dollar
nike deal
anyway the point is that the kids who
didn't know nothing about no christian
lightner knew about players on team usa
like kobe kevin durant and lebron james
and now
somehow
the name mike shishevsky rings out in
the streets like nicki barnes
cause kay get love in the streets
so it don't matter if we in manhattan or
harlem
they know coach k man
it's crazy
think about how crazy that is in the 80s
parents from duke wouldn't let their
kids get within 40 acres of harlem now
this team looks like the kids who sell
you candy on the train
the all-academic duke team that
everybody talked about was full of one
and doners
but it's funny
hardly anyone calls shachewski a
hypocrite because when he did it that
was just the game
because he was the game
are you a supporter of this one and done
rule don't make any difference if you're
supportive of it we have no control over
it what you have to do like you have to
do in business is adapt and adapt he did
because black culture did eventually
take over college basketball
but i'll be honest
college basketball was better when duke
was the official team of white america
every game felt like one of those
episodes of family feud
think about basketball like the name
tyrone
after a while
white folks just let us keep it for
ourselves
but you know some folks won't let us
have nothing
and for four decades a lot of fans felt
like coach k was the one person who just
couldn't let us have this one thing
it all felt
like personal
even if it wasn't
so believe me when i say sincerely
happy retirement coach k
no one has been wishing for this day
longer than us
so to commemorate the real legacy of
coach k we decided to give him his very
own museum exhibit
check it out
to help the black community process
coach k's 42-year reign of terror we
opened the boys in blue coach k's march
across america an exhibit at the
schomburg center for black research and
culture in harlem
all day we led the public on tours
through our many exhibits highlighting
coach k's destruction of our beautiful
black college basketball teams this
section of the exhibit is called trail
of sneers look at this picture right now
what do you see a coach talking to a ref
or a karen talking to a cop
same vibes sir i see your i see your
face is scrunching you've seen these
faces before
and were they bringing you good news
never were they bringing you positivity
never were they uplifting you never i
want you to look at this one right here
what do you get when you look at this
picture a lot of anger in his eyes
how he feels about himself and others so
you see self-hate the anger's coming
from within that man right there stole
my dreams talk to me i used to play high
school basketball with jamal mashburn
and you lost to him are you still
friends with your mom right absolutely
is he still troubled by what happened
absolutely if you could express your
feelings about coach k in one word what
would that word be
terror
terror
i think that about sums it up let's move
on to the next section everybody he
wasn't the only one coach k terrified
our exhibit also showcased the
nightmarish illustrations the children
of detroit drew after duke defeated the
fab five in the 1992 ncaa championship
game
as a native of detroit michigan this is
only giving me ptsd so you saw the game
that these kids saw
and i was that age the city was down
altogether
i'm sure the water got a little dirtier
after
this defeat
that's flint
my bad my bad
dozens of artifacts told the stories of
black trauma like amino timberlake's
jersey that christian leighton stomped
on with his punk ass
coach k's single game salary and the
salaries of every duke player from 1980
to present
and the embarrassing linchpins to coach
k's success
the next section of the exhibit is
called the wall of unimpressive whites
it was these goofy white athletes that
were out there beating
our amazing
black college basketball teams and of
course sheldon williams he is not white
but he's
white by association look at this guy he
looks like
top guns co-pilot what was his name
goose goose this goose looking
[ __ ]
beating all our teams and that's wrong
you all ready for the next section of
the exhibit yeah i need some water i'm
i'm getting pissed off and i get it
these corn-fed cop-calling cul-de-sac
dwelling cockazoids and sheldon had
shattered the dreams of our heroes
thankfully our altar of the ncaa dead
homies gave patrons a chance to pay
their respect chris webber that was my
dude man
i had the
i had the black socks anybody anybody
had the black socks y'all had the the
black socks
socks but their pain was nothing
compared to what some have endured and
now we've reached the jaylen rose part
of our exhibit ladies and gentlemen
jaylen rose a true survivor of coach k's
march across america
i'm on four against coach k
he beat me each time
even once
after my uncle passed then they came to
ann arbor
i had a patch on my jersey and
everything
it still didn't matter this is not
fiction
this ain't no wax figure there's a real
one right here i once dribbled the ball
across half court against bobby hurley
and he just failed for no reason and
they called the charge goddamn flopping
who's bobby hurley a miniature point
guard for the duke blue devils small man
are those really his shorts
they are we were extra baggy shorts
bobby hurley chose
a kid's medium
too much thigh for my eye damn right and
we shouldn't allow ourselves to be
terrorized by these creamy thighed
oshkosh b got sized devils these duke
athletes aren't monsters they're suckers
led by a five foot ten inch tyrant that
we as a community have overcome
our day had come to an end but of course
no black history museum would be
complete without a cool down area to
process our emotions breathe in and
return to the real world with
a renewed sense of self and always
remember that coach k collected over 40
years of victories
but danny green still put his balls on
greg paulus's forehead
keep hope alive
you